>>HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE RALLIED
THIS WEEK IN ST. LOUIS TO
SUPPORT A DISPLAY OF THE
NATIONAL MOTTO "IN GOD WE
TRUST."
A WOMAN PROTESTING THE MOTTO WAS
ESCORTED OUT OF THE COUNCIL LAST
MONTH.
>> THIS HAS CREATED AN
ATMOSPHERE OF HOSTILITY AND
INTIMIDATION TOWARD THOSE THAT
DON'T BELIEVE IN A HIGHER POWER.
>> THAT WOMAN IS HERE TONIGHT
WITH HER SIDE OF THE STORY.
ALSO JOINING US IS MISSOURI
STATE SENATOR.
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
THAT MOTTO "IN GOD WE TRUST"
REALLY SEEMS TO SEND YOU OVER
THE EDGE AND I WANT TO KIND OF
FIGURE IT OUT, UNDERSTANDING WHY
YOU THINK IT'S THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF RELIGION IN THE UNITED
STATES.
GO AHEAD.
>> WELL, I DIDN'T SAY THAT IT
IS THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
RELIGION, BUT IT IS CERTAINLY
THE ENDORSEMENT AND THE
ADVANCEMENT OF RELIGION BY OUR
GOVERNMENT.
SO IT SHOULD SEND EVERYBODY OVER
THE EDGE IF THEY VALUE THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION.
AND I DO.
>> WHICH PART OF IT?
>> IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO ME.
>> WHICH PART DO YOU FEEL THIS
VIOLATES?
>> SO THE FIRST AMENDMENT
ESTABLISHMENT CLAUSE.
>> RIGHT.
WHICH IS WHY I SAID ESTABLISHED
RELIGION.
>> WELL, IT HAS BEEN ALSO
INTERPRETED -- THE SUPREME COURT
HAS MADE IT CLEAR.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THE LEMON TEST?
YOU ARE.
GREAT, GREAT.
SO THEN THAT'S WHY I WOULD THINK
THAT YOU WOULD ALSO BE UPSET
ABOUT THE ENDORSEMENT AND
ADVANCEMENT OF RELIGION BY OUR
GOVERNMENT, WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE THE
MOTTO "IN GOD WE TRUST" IS ABOUT
RELIGION.
THERE IS NO SECULAR PURPOSE.
>> WHAT RELIGION DOES IT
ENDORSE?
>> SO ABSOLUTELY CHRISTIANITY.
AND I AM HAPPY TO EXPLAIN WHY
IT'S DEFINITELY CHRISTIANITY.
>> LET ME JUST GO THROUGH FOR
OUR VIEWERS WHICH DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE LEMON TEST, HERE
ARE THE THREE THINGS THE COURT
JUST MADE UP.
THEY MADE THIS UP AND SAID,
OKAY, THIS IS OUR TEST.
THE ISSUE, THE GOVERNMENT ACTION
HAS TO HAVE A PRIMARY EFFECT
THAT NEITHER ADVANCES NOR
INHIBIT RELIGION.
IT CAN'T BE AN EXPRESSIVE
GOVERNMENT ENTANGLE IN RELIGION
EITHER.
AND IT HAS TO HAVE PRIMARILY A
SECULAR PURPOSE, A GOVERNMENT
ACTION.
THIS WAS PAID FOR BY PRIVATE
MONEY.
THIS IS PRIVATE MONEY PAID FOR
THIS.
AND MY QUESTION TO YOU IS HOW
DOES THIS EXPRESSIVELY ENTANGLE
THE GOVERNMENT IN RELIGION,
WHICH IS ONE OF THE PRONGS OF
THE TEST.
>> RIGHT.
LAURA, SO THE ENTANGLEMENT PART
DOES NOT HAVE TO BE PART OF IT.
THERE ARE THREE PARTS OF THE
LEMON TEST.
AND SO IT HAS TO -- AN ACTION BY
THE GOVERNMENT HAS TO PASS EACH
ONE OF THOSE THREE.
>> OKAY.
SO IN GOD WE TRUST ON THE COINS,
IS THAT ALSO -- WE HAVE TO ALL
REDO ALL THE COINAGE IN THIS
COUNTRY AS WELL?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S ALSO
THAT'S ALSO UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
>> CONGRESSMAN, YOU CAN ADDRESS
-- ATHEISTS ARE REALLY UNHAPPY
ABOUT THIS AND THEY WANT
SOMETHING DONE.
>> THEY SURE ARE, LAURA.
AS YOU KNOW, THE MOTTO "IN GOD
WE TRUST" GOES BACK MANY YEARS.
IT FIRST APPEARED IN THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
AND IN 1956, CONGRESS EWE  --
UNANIMOUSLY IN BOTH HOUSES.
AND OF COURSE WE KNOW IT APPEARS
ON OUR NATIONAL COINAGE, IN THE
HALLS OF CONGRESS IN THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE.
AND THERE'S NOTHING WHATSOEVER
WRONG WITH THE CITY DECIDING
THEY WILL ACCEPT THAT DONATION
OF THE "IN GOD WE TRUST" DISPLAY
FOR THEIR CITY COUNCIL CHAMBERS.
>> A LOT OF OTHER STATES ARE
LOOKING AT THIS TOO BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENS IS YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF
ATHEIST ORGANIZATIONS,
AND I THINK WHAT HAPPENS IS --
AND I WANT TO GET YOU IN ON
THIS.
OUR FOUNDING WAS A FOUNDING
BASED ON LIBERTY, LIBERTY THAT
CAME NOT FROM THE GOVERNMENT BUT
CAME FROM GOD.
THOMAS JEFFERSON SAID, 1781, GOD
WHO GAVE US LIFE GAVE US
LIBERTY.
AND CAN THE LIBERTIES OF A
NATION BE THOUGHT SECURE WHEN WE
HAVE REMOVED THEIR ONLY FIRM
BASIS, A CONVICTION IN THE MINDS
OF THE PEOPLE THAT THESE
LIBERTIES ARE A GIFT FROM GOD.
OUR FOUNDERS DIDN'T BELIEVE IN
ORGANIZED RELIGION, BUT GOD WAS
IMPORTANT.
>> SO WHY DIDN'T THEY MENTION
GOD ONE TIME IN THE ENTIRE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION?
THERE'S NO MENTION OF GOD, THE
BIBLE, CHRISTIANITY NOT WAS.
BUT THE ONLY TIME THEY MENTION
RELIGION IS TO SAY THAT THERE
SHALL BE NO RELIGIOUS TEST FOR
MY ELECTED LEADER.
AND I WANT TO CLARIFY WHY THIS
IS CLEARLY AN ENDORSEMENT OF
CHRISTIANITY.
THE JEWISH FAITH SAYS THAT YOU
DO NOT PRINT THE WORD "GOD."
G-O-D WOULD NEVER BE IN THE
JEWISH FAITH ON A SIDE.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY NOT THE JEWISH
GOD.
HINDUS BELIEVE IN MULTIPLE GODS.
BUDDHISTS DO NOT BELIEVE IN A
GOD.
>> BUT MOST OVERWHELMINGLY
AMERICANS BELIEVE IN GOD.
I THINK IT'S 89%, 88%.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SCREAM.
WE HEAR YOU.
I THINK THE POINT IS MOST PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT OUR COUNTRY WAS
FOUNDED UPON THIS NOTION OF
LIBERTY THAT CAME FROM ON HIGH.
WE ARE ENDOWED BY OUR CREATOR
WITH CERTAIN INALIENABLE RIGHTS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LIBERTY AND
OUR LIBERTY COMES FROM GOD.
AND THE FACT THAT ATHEISTS ARE
SO -- I ALSO THINK, SALLY, PART
OF IT IS A LOT OF ATHEISTS, THEY
WANT TO BE CLOSER TO GOD BUT
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE CLOSER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS, BUT --
>>WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> WE PRAY FOR PEOPLE AS
CHRISTIANS AND OUR FRIENDS IN
THE JEWISH AND MUSLIM FAITH PRAY
FOR HEARTS TO CHANGE, .
>> AND I THINK IN THIS SCENARIO
RIGHT NOW, ATHEISTS ACTUALLY
TURN OFF A LOT OF PEOPLE BECAUSE
IT'S NOT HURTING ANYONE IN
SAYING "IN GOD WE TRUST."
>>DO YOU REALIZE THAT YOU'RE
PROMOTING HOSTILITY AND
PREJUDICE AND DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST ATHEIST AGNOSTIC SECULAR
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THIS COUNTRY.
>> OUR COUNTRY HAS SECULAR
PRACTICES ALL OVER THE PLACE.
YOU'RE DOMINATING THE
CONVERSATION.
LET'S GET THE SENATOR IN.
>> IT'S CHRISTIANITY, LAURA.
>> WELL, LAURA, AS YOU KNOW,
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS CONGRESS
SHALL MAKE NO LAW RESPECTING AN
ESTABLISHMENT OF RELIGION.
AN ESTABLISHMENT OF RELIGION IN
ITS HISTORICAL CONTENT MEANT
THAT CONGRESS WOULD NEVER MAKE
AMERICA A BAPTIST OR CATHOLIC
COUNTRY OR A BUDDHIST COUNTRY.
>> I'M NOT ASKING FOR THAT.
>> WE'LL HAVE YOU BACK, SALLY,
BECAUSE THIS HAS BEEN A --
>>AND I DID NOT GO OVER MY